de toute façon l'euro c'était parce
qu'on ne voulait pas adopter le
deutschmark pour l'ensemble des pays
européens
donc on a on a donc créé cet euro parce
que c'était pas politiquement correct de
dire que le deutsch mark avait circulé
dont dans les pays européens mais elle
allait être cette monnaie européenne qui
de fait était avant avant l'euro est
d'ailleurs c'est si c'est drôle puisque
ce quand on regarde le pouvoir
représenté par l'euro on s'aperçoit
qu'il est pas plus que le poids du
deutsche mark
avant l'euro donc voilà il ouvrit une
preuve elle est bien là et bien
évidemment l'allemagne a bien voulu
fable s'ils voulaient bien changé le nom
de sa monnaie pour pour faire plus
politiquement correct mais elle ne
voulait pas changer ce qui la gestion
monétaire et budgétaire qui allait avec
le type de monnaie qu'elle a toujours
voulu préserver
depuis donc depuis cette fameuse crise
donc des années 30
donc là est la question elle est
effectivement là elle et elle a été bien
posée je pense par par frédéric
auparavant c'est à dire que si on vient
on est venu tous pour des raisons
différentes haut niveau dans la zone
européenne
et le problème c'est qu'à un moment
donné et bien il faut tenir compte des
réalités et il faut savoir pourquoi on
est venu et s'ils ont effectivement en
france venus pour avoir retrouvé du
pouvoir et bien effectivement la
mauvaise nouvelle pour nous c'est qu'en
fait on en n'a pas retrouvé et
effectivement on a plutôt eu un abandon
de souveraineté sur plusieurs questions
mais je dirais que cet abandon de
souveraineté de toute façon au niveau
monétaire on l'avait déjà de fait parce
que quand vous faites partie d'un
système le système monétaire européen
avant l'euro de toute façon on n'a pas
non plus beaucoup de souveraineté sur sa
politique monétaire quand on veut rester
dans un système de taux de change fixe
avec le reste des autres pays dont
cornet ça je dirais que c'est pas le
c'est pas la bande aux plus grands
[Musique]